foreign
product manager for Google Cloud
database migration service all DMs
today I want to introduce you to the new
integrated schema and code conversion
built in DMS that allows you to
modernize the Oracle workloads and
migrate them to Cloud SQL postgresql
DMS provides a simple integrated
experience to guide you through every
step of the migration process starting
from converting your Source database
coding schema to moving your data with
minimal downtime
simple secured and serverless you don't
need to worry about managing or
monitoring instances
now let's walk through the DMS
experience starting with introducing the
new resource in DMS conversion workspace
conversion workspace is your playground
for everything related to converting
your Source schema in code conversion
workspaces like connection profiles that
represent the information needed to
connect to both your source and your
destination database are reusable across
multiple migration jobs so you can
utilize the same resources for multiple
migrations
now let's create a new conversion
workspace
we start by adding some information
about the conversion workspace
as in other creation flows like a
migration job DMS makes it easy to know
the source and destination prerequisites
within the creation process
here I'm choosing the specific
connection profile that I want to
connect to I already have a connection
profile prepared with my Oracle source
as in any flow in DMs I can test and
validate that all my pre-configurations
were done correctly
perfect DMS is able to connect to my
source and I can go ahead and pull this
whole schema I can view my entire source
with all the variety of objects like
tables procedures function and packages
I can now choose which objects I want to
convert first but don't worry DMS allows
me to be flexible and add more objects
later on
I'm selecting tables functions
procedures and views
now let's convert and continue DMS will
convert the selected objects from Oracle
to possible SQL dialect
this is the main conversion workspace
screen let's take a quick tool
on the left side we can see the Oracle
tree that includes all the objects I
selected in the previous step
I can view the password sequel tree
which shows me how DMS converted the
source
for each object I can view the SQL of
the source and the destination
I can also view the conversion status
can be no issues which means DMS
converted these objects without any
issues
review recommended which means the DMS
converted this object but some attention
is required for me to make sure it's
aligned with my expectations in this
example I can see messages about
precision and unsupported types
and the last status is action required
which means the DMS was not able to
convert the entire object
the Oracle function Cisco ID doesn't
exist in positive SQL I will update the
code to fix the issue and Save
you can see that the status has changed
to modify let's say that now I'm happy
with the status of all objects I
initially chose and I want to add more
objects
let's add the other schema as well and
convert
great I can see that I don't have any
outstanding issues I need to address I
can view the converted possible SQL tree
and I'm ready to move to the next step
applying the converted schema on the
destination
apply means to create a converted schema
encode on the destination this would be
the last step before creating or
starting my migration as this step
actually changes my destination DMS
allows me to test it first I can perform
test apply which will check if there are
any issues with a converted puzzle SQL
that I need to address since this is a
demo and not production let's keep the
test and click apply
great DMS can connect to my classical
destination next DMS allows me to select
which objects I would like to apply this
allows me another level of flexibility
in case I don't want to apply all
objects at once let's choose to apply
the first schema
perfect I can see that the apply was
done successfully now I can move on to
the migration job creation
I will add some details on my migration
jobs like connection profiles and the
conversion workspace I would like to use
now I can select which objects I would
actually like to move
we select all objects and move to the
next step
I can again test the migration job for
any outstanding issues now that there
are no outstanding issues I can initiate
the creation and the start of my
migration job
that's it now my aggression job is
running and all that is left is to
monitor it and finalize the migration
when ready
Google Cloud's DMS with the new
integrated conversion workspace is the
fast easy and reliable way to both
convert and migrate to minimal downtime
to a managed open source Cloud sick for
positive SQL database now it's your turn
to give it a try
you can get started from the Google
Cloud console or learn more by following
the links in the description
thanks for watching
thank you